we begin here this hour with a special
distinction for one of america's
national parks while most win acclaim
for what is best seen by day
one park in colorado is being rewarded
for what can only be seen
in the dark mesa verde was recently
named another international dark sky
park for the exceptional quality of its
star-filled nights it's already been
designated as a world heritage site
featuring the best preserved structures
of the pueblo people nancy chen visited
mesa verde to see the very best that
both day and night
have to offer
and what you're going to see right here
is an exposed
kiva this is where t.j etsy says her
ancestors once gathered nearly a
thousand years ago
a thriving community of towers and homes
molded with sandstone and mortar 150
rooms in all
it's nestled inside colorado's mesa
verde national park not far from the
four corners another kind of crossroads
in this rugged landscape between
breathtaking natural beauty and the
careful preservation of life so many
generations ago
when was this built
it was probably built about 11 11 50.
this is cliff palace the largest cliff
dwelling in north america once inhabited
by southwestern american indians now
known as ancestral pueblo people who
farmed on the mesa tops above
[Applause]
the first permanent homes were built in
the 500s but according to pueblo oral
stories their history goes back much
earlier i'm going to tell you they've
been here forever
part of our traditional stories our
culture and where we came from we were
already here mesa verde is a very
special place yes it is
because it's still alive
it's a place where
the ancestors are here no matter where
you go
even though you can't see them
you sense they are here
around 600 alcove sites are scattered
throughout the park and at least 3
million objects have been preserved
within the dwellings providing a glimpse
into how bustling mesa verde once was
the population of mesa verde in the
1100s was
about the same as the population of
paris park ranger spencer burke says
pueblo people began to migrate away from
mesa verde in the 13th century the exact
reasons are unknown but archaeologists
tied the move to cultural and
environmental changes they built new
communities nearby but their homes here
remained these cliff dwellings that were
built under these natural alcoves
protected these buildings from the
elements for hundreds of years you can
see the original plaster and paint on
the walls
you don't have to stretch your
imagination to see these as
thriving communities but just as
important to pueblo people as what's
below these expansive mesas is what's
above
well we're walking into the middle of
downtown mesa verde of the late 1200s
this is sun temple here so this was the
center of the action this was where
everyone in the surrounding area
probably came many of sun temple's uses
remain a mystery but some archaeologists
believe ancestral pueblo people may have
used the building itself as a calendar
planning farming and ceremonies based on
the cycles of the moon sun and stars
cliff palace is just across the canyon
from us and researchers have found that
from within marked spots inside cliff
palace looking over the walls of sun
temple they could observe the lunar
standstill and the sunset on the winter
solstice the night sky over mesa verde
today remains among the darkest one
percent in the country what is the
connection of the ancestral pueblo
people with the skies
the skies
were magic
the skies of the universe it was a very
powerful
omen it was a foreteller
a foreseer you know for the people who
looked at the sky for those answers
the same starry constellations used by
ancestral pueblo people still captivate
visitors today even with the naked eye
but especially those with a knack for
night vision
the night sky
unites us all as humans betty maya foote
works with the international dark sky
association and is an astrophotographer
the non-profit celebrated its 30th
anniversary this year its goal to save
vanishing night skies
in the united states and europe 99 of
the population lives under light
polluted skies
so it's a huge problem light pollution
is increasing at twice the rate of human
population growth the organization
awards certifications to locations
around the world with exceptionally high
quality night skies there are 181 dark
sky places in more than 20 countries
what happens if we don't preserve the
night sky
i think we lose we lose our sense of awe
our sense of wonder and our sense of
kind of the mystery of the universe
right in 2021 mesa verde was certified
as the world's 100th international dark
sky park burke spearheaded the effort we
at mesa verde have extremely dark skies
but
every year they get a little brighter
and
here at mesa verde where we protect the
history of the pueblo people
those stars are part of the cultural
heritage when you can't see those stars
when you can't see the milky way you
lose that connection to the ancestors
you lose that connection to our to our
future generations this is certainly
narrow
[Laughter]
now i feel like old grandma coming down
here
because of those efforts that thread now
continues to link those who came before
to those who visit today
what place does mesa verde hold today
for
people who are pueblo
it's a place to come home to and let the
ancestors
tell you everything is going to be all
right
that sense of home enduring more than
850 years transcending across
generations i can imagine myself being
back
thousands of years ago say right here
and just looking up
and knowing that this is this is forever
this is universal
for cbs saturday morning nancy chen mesa
verde colorado
road trip oh wow
yeah i mean no it's just like amazing
they've been able to keep and preserved
that night sky night you know light
pollution is there's nothing that's a
problem it's such a problem it's true
and there's there's nothing like going
what it did destroy in grand canyon
which is a dark sky location as well i
mean just being there when it is that
pitch black it's something that so many
people these days never get to
experience
i haven't
i haven't either
i really haven't so our i think our road
trip list
between 122 and 130. we got to start
checking i think also here the history
behind it too yeah and what it meant it
just you learn about a place that you i
didn't i didn't know existed in that way
yeah and nancy chen and emily
d'alessandro both said
there's just something magical about
that spot right just
left them with such an awe so we need a
lot of time off to go great job well
they're on the mccurdy so you can ask
them right now let's go